is it possible to say
something that kind of captivates keeps
being
brought up by physicists which is gage
theory gauge symmetry
as one of the more complicated type of
symmetries is there is that is there an
easy explanation what the heck it is
is that something that comes up on your
mind at all
well i'm not a mathematical physicist
but i can say this it is
certainly true that it's been a very
useful
notion in physics to try to say like
what are the symmetry groups like of the
world like what are the symmetries under
which
things don't change right so we just i
think we talked a little bit earlier
about
it should be a basic principle that a
theorem that's true here is also true
over there
yes and same for a physical law right i
mean if gravity is like this over here
it should also be like this over there
okay what that's saying is we think
translation in space
should be a symmetry all the laws of
physics should be unchanged
if the symmetry we have in mind is a
very simple one like translation
and so then um there becomes a question
like what are the symmetries
of the actual world with its physical
laws
and one way of thinking is an
oversimplification but like one way of
thinking of this big
shift from uh
before einstein to after is that we just
changed our idea about what the
fundamental group of
symmetries were so that things like the
lorenz contraction things like these
bizarre
relativistic phenomena or lorenz would
have said
oh to make this work we need a thing to
um
to change its shape if it's moving
yeah nearly a speed of light well under
the new frame of
framework it's much better you're like
oh no i wasn't changing its shape you
were just wrong about what counted as a
symmetry now that we have this new group
the so-called lorenz group
now that we understand what the
symmetries really are we see it was just
an illusion that the
the thing was changing its shape yeah so
you can then describe the sameness of
things
under this weirdness that exactly that
is general relativity for example
yeah yeah still um
i wish there was a simpler explanation
of like exactly i mean
you know gauge symmetry is a pretty
simple general concept
about rulers being deformed
i it's just i i uh i've actually just
personally been
on a search not a very uh rigorous
or aggressive search but for um
something i personally enjoy which is
taking complicated
concepts and finding the sort of minimal
example
that i can play around with especially
programmatically that's great i mean
that this is what we try to train our
students to do right i mean in class
this is exactly what
this is like best pedagogical practice i
do
hope there's simple explanation
especially like
i've uh in my sort of uh
drunk random walk drunk walk whatever
that's called
uh sometimes stumble into the world of
topology
and like quickly like you know when you
like go to a party and you realize this
is
not the right party for me
so whenever i go into topology it's like
so much math
everywhere i don't even know what it
feels like
this is me like being a hater is i think
there's way too much math like
they're two the cool kids who just want
to have like everything is expressed
through math
as because they're actually afraid to
express stuff simply through
language that's that's my hater
formulation of topology
but at the same time i'm sure that's
very necessary to do sort of rigorous
discussion but
i feel like but don't you think that's
what gauge symmetry is like i mean it's
not a field i know well but it certainly
seems like yes it is like that okay
but my problem with topology okay and
even like differential geom and
differential geometry
is like you're talking about beautiful
things
like if they could be visualized it's
open question if
everything could be visualized but
you're talking about things that could
be
visually stunning i think
but they are hidden underneath all of
that math
like if you look at the papers that are
written in topology if you look at all
the discussions on stack exchange
they're all math dense math heavy and
the only kind of
visual things that emerge every once in
a while
is like uh something like a mobius strip
every once in a while some kind of uh
[Music]
simple visualizations well there's the
the vibration there's the the hop
vibration or all those kinds of things
that somebody some grad student from
like 20 years ago wrote a program in
fortran to visualize it and that's it
and it's just you know it makes me sad
because um
those are visual disciplines just like
computer vision is a visual discipline
so you can provide a lot of visual
examples i wish topology
was more excited and in love with
visualizing some of the ideas
i mean you could say that but i would
say for me a picture of the hot
vibration does nothing for me
whereas like when you're like oh it's
like about the quaternions it's like a
subgroup of the quaternions and i'm like
oh so now i see what's going on like why
didn't you just say that why were you
like showing me this stupid picture
instead of telling me what you were
talking about
oh yeah yeah i'm just saying
no but it goes back to what we were
saying about teaching that like people
are different in what they'll respond to
so i think there's no i mean
i'm very opposed to the idea that
there's one right way to explain things
i think there's a huge variation in like
you know our brains like have all these
like weird like hooks and loops and it's
like very hard to know like what's going
to latch on and it's not going to be the
same thing
for everybody so well i think
monoculture is bad right i think that's
and i think we're agreeing on that point
that like
it's good that there's like a lot of
different ways in and a lot of different
ways to describe these ideas because
different people are going to find
different things illuminating but
that said i think there's a lot to be
discovered
when you
force little like silos of brilliant
people
to kind of uh find a middle ground
or like uh aggregate or
come together in a way so there's like
people that do love visual things
i mean there's there's a lot of
disciplines especially in computer
science
that they're obsessed with visualizing
visualizing data
visualizing neural networks i mean
neural networks themselves are
fundamentally visual there's a lot
of work in computer vision that's very
visual and then coming together with
some
some folks that were like deeply
rigorous and are like totally lost in
multi-dimensional space where it's
hard to even bring them back down to 3d
uh
they're very comfortable in this
multi-dimensional space so forcing them
to kind of work together to communicate
because it's not just about public
communication of ideas
it's also i feel like when you're forced
to do that public communication like you
did with your book
i think deep profound ideas can be
discovered that's like applicable for
research
and for science like there's something
about that simplification or not
simplification but
distillation or condensation or whatever
the hell you call it compression
of ideas that somehow actually
stimulates creativity
and uh i'd be excited to see more of
that in the
in in the mathematics community can you
let me make a crazy metaphor
maybe it's a little bit like the
relation between prose and poetry right
i mean if you you might say like why do
we need anything more than prose you're
trying to convey some information so you
just like
say it um well poetry does something
right it's sort of
you might think of it as a kind of
compression of course not all poetry is
compressed like not awesome some of it
is quite
baggy but like um
you are kind of often it's compressed
right a lyric poem is often sort of like
a compression of what would take a long
time and be complicated to explain prose
into sort of
a different mode that it's going to hit
in a different way
you